hi i'm christopher hein i just wanted to
make a quick announcement to you guys so
i'm going to be slowing down the youtube
videos a little bit again
i'm going to start putting most of my
videos on my patreon page so i have a
patreon page
you can find the link below and
everything's going to come out there
first and
stuff will still come out on youtube but
it's going to come out at a much slower
rate now so
if you're really interested in the
material um you can join the patreon
link and it'll be coming out on a
regular basis
but the youtube videos are not going to
stop they're just going to slow down a
little bit
i really feel like for the most part a
lot of my aikido stuff has been
put up now and you can see us doing it
both live and in drills and
and in demonstration any kind of stuff
so you can see the
basic idea of my system and i'm putting
it out there so aikido students
will train and practice that stuff so
you guys need to do that stuff so if
you're interested in how it works
it doesn't matter if i solved everything
you've got to do it yourself so i feel
like the mainstay that material is out
there
i will add supplemental stuff as we go
and if you want some more help
and to look at more stuff in the details
in the following weeks
you can check out the patreon link i'm
christa fry thanks a lot for watching
appreciate it